cette crise elle est révélatrice
d'énormément de dysfonctionnements que
nous avons dans notre société comme vous
dis-je écrit un livre aussi sur les
excès de la finance
j'ai pas mal aussi travailler sur tout
ce qui l est les questions agricoles
dont on voit que cette crise elle
regroupe tout ça il ya des chercheurs
qui ont montré des chercheurs comme
serge morand où jean françois guégan le
lien entre la baisse de la biodiversité
et l'augmentation du nombre d'épidémie
que ç'a un impact que la baisse de
biodiversité un impact sur le
l'augmentation du nombre des d'épidémie
donc c'est aussi une crise écologique
que nous avons alors on pourrait se dire
qu'il ya eu énormément d'épidémie ni
d'un an auparavant qui a toujours eu
d'épidémie des épidémies il ya moins de
gens qui sont infectés par des épidémies
mais le nombre de d'épidémie a augmenté
depuis 1940 de l'ordre s'étaient
multipliées par 10 d'après les chiffres
de serge mourant donc on voit que le nom
d'épidémie augmentent
à cause notamment de cette baisse de
biodiversité les animaux sauvages en
moins de places pourra pour vivre se
déplace dans des dans des zones où alors
même il ya de la baisse de biodiversité
au sein des animaux sauvages par exemple
les prédateurs comme les lynx ou les
hyènes sont moins nombreux ces
prédateurs premier les plus importants
il ya moins du coup il y a plus de
rongeurs qui vont être véhicules de
pathogènes et aussi cette déforestation
qui est parfois due notamment à une
agriculture intensive pas toujours mais
qui peut être dû à ça par exemple pour
faire des palmiers à huile on va
déforester et et tout ça peut avoir un
impact sur après l'augmentation du
nombre d'épidémie
[Musique]